[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute ein
richtig richtig leckeres hauptgericht
und zwar kanisch zitronen hohen ich muss
vorab sagen es ist auf meine art ist es
schon recht traditionell allerdings eine
entscheidende sache die ich anders mache
ich nehme keine salz zitrone die bekommt
man einfach relativ schwer und eine
zitrone hat man immer daheim und wenn
man das nämlich mal spontan machen
möchte dann hat man eigentlich alle
zutaten die bekommt man wirklich in den
standard supermärkten und ich fange
jetzt direkt an mit meiner marinade und
dafür nehme ich mir moment ich nehme
erst mal und ich hatte das im ersten
fastentag übrigens gemacht und es war
sooo lecker ich habe zwar mit gefilmt
aber manche rezepte die gehen einfach
nicht im schnelldurchlauf ich zeig euch
am ende des videos mal was für ein video
daraus entstanden ist für tik tok und
dann könnt ihr euch das mal angucken und
hier mal in die kommentare schreiben was
würdet ihr besser im schnelldurchlauf
oder wirklich schritt für schritt
erklärt olivenöl ist jetzt tritt für
meine marinade zitrone kommt erst ganz
am schluss ich habe es nur anfangs schon
mal erwähnt weil es ist ein zitronen
hohen und daher ist ja ganz normal dass
man sie verwendet beziehungsweise die
seite zitrone verwendet wenn ihr mögt
schreibt es in die kommentare dann kann
ich euch mal zeigen wie ihr seid
zitronen selber einlegen ist nämlich
auch ganz einfach dauert nur vier wochen
bis man sie verwenden kann es ihm fand
ich ein bisschen unpraktisch ich würde
es hier noch mit paprikapulver edelsüß
ich habe hier müssen und kurkuma
irgendwann darf nicht fehlen knoblauch
salz und pfeffer und dann kommen es ist
ganz typischer dürften nicht darauf
verzichten koriander und petersilie noch
mit dazu
[Musik]
also die marinade sieht schon sehr gut
aus also würde ich diese farbe schon
sehe da geht mir richtig das herz auch
wenn wir keinen koriander fan seite gibt
es ja auch viele die satten grüns nicht
so meint ich muss sagen ich bin ich der
größte koriander fällen aber er schmeckt
s nicht so intensiv raus aber man merkt
auf jeden fall dass es dieses typische
marokkanisches leer ist daher tut mir
den gefallen und verzichtet nicht drauf
ich gebe jetzt noch so ein bisschen
wasser rein denn wir wollen sich zu ölig
der bei olivenöl verwendet da ist es
auch ganz wichtig dass sie ein gutes
leckeres olivenöl verwendet natürlich am
besten
nativ extra und das macht sich auch im
geschmack bemerkbar und da werde ich
jetzt einfach folgendes machen die
marinade kommt jetzt auch mein hähnchen
das habe ich schon gesäubert und beim
hähnchen ist es so man nimmt eigentlich
ein ganzes händchen und zerteilt dass
das hatte ich auch als ich das mal
gemacht habe hatte ich es auch gemacht
oder er fragt den metzger ob er das für
euch macht wenn ihr das nicht machen
möchtet oder ihr nehmt euch einfach
hähnchenteile am liebsten mit haut mit
ein bisschen fett gerne auch mit knochen
weil das sind ja alles geschmacksträger
und ist welches schön marinieren wenn
die zeit habt lasst es gerne eine stunde
gerne auch zwei lass es gerne in der
marinade so ein bisschen ziehen wenn ihr
gar keine zeit hat ist auch okay dann
könnt ihr das auch direkt weiter er
könnte damit direkt weiter kochen aber
ich habe jetzt gerade ein bisschen zeit
nicht zu viel aber eine halbe stunde
werde ich das ganze jetzt marinieren
lassen
[Musik]
so jetzt jetzt weiter hier am herd ich
habe jetzt hier einen ausreichend großen
topf gibt da ein bisschen öl rhein ihr
braucht nicht viel denn ihr habt ja
schon am fleisch und wir wollen sie auch
wirklich wie gesagt nicht zu fettig
haben da habe ich jetzt eine zwiebel
fein geschnitten ob jetzt eine normale
weiße nimmt oder ein rotes vollkommen
zufällig nur die rote da die gebe ich
das schon mit dazu und dann kann
eigentlich da direkt mit drin das
fleisch angebraten werden von beiden
seiten ausreichend lang so dass einfach
röstaromen entstehen wo ich ein bisschen
schärfer auch anbraten und dann wird das
ganze mit wasser abgelöscht
[Musik]
nachdem ihr das wasser dazu gegeben habe
darf das ganze jetzt köcheln es braucht
schon ne weile bis das ganze hähnchen
durch ich verrate ich gleich meine zeit
ich mache nämlich wenn ich nicht filme
alles immer so nach gefühl mit achtet
nicht auf zeiten aber für euch gebe ich
euch natürlich immer die ganz genauen
angaben und zeiten durch und ist quasi
halbzeit und nicht wert dass ich habe
das ganze mal umdrehen ihr habt sicher
gemerkt dass das wasser nicht bis oben
hin voll ist das hat einfach den grund
dass wir gleich eine sehnige soße
möchten aber jetzt drehe ich erstmal man
fleisch um das ist auch von allen seiten
chinas abbekommt deckel noch mal drauf
zu ende garen lassen und in der
zwischenzeit könnt ihr schon mal den
backofen vorheizen richtig schön volle
power 220 grad ober unterhitze wenn das
fleisch wird gleich quasi noch so ein
bisschen im ofen gegrillt die soße wird
schön sämig und die oliven kommt dazu
und alles wird einfach richtig lecker
selbst sind gute 20 minuten rum das
fleisch ist gegart und dann machen wir
jetzt folgen dass wir nehmen das fleisch
raus ich nehme jetzt einfach ihr könnt
euch auch ein backblech nehmen oder
sowas in der art ich nehme jetzt einfach
hier die auflaufform er falls dann doch
noch mal irgendwie so ein bisschen was
vom öl tropft dann habe ich keine
sauerei und einfach drauf geben und noch
mal schön in den ofen wie gesagt 220
grad ober unterhitze den parallel
vorgeheizt und dann nochmal so ungefähr
10 12 minuten im ofen schön post werden
lassen die soße ist schon ein bisschen
ein reduziert aber sie darf noch ein
bisschen mehr ein reduziert und da
kommen wir jetzt noch die oliven
dazugewinnen oliven sind ganz typisch
und zitronensaft denn es ist ja
schließlich zitronen hähnchen und dann
lass dir das ohne deckel noch mal so ein
bisschen einkochen ihr könnt auch selber
entscheiden wenn ihr so schon mögen das
ist halt ein bisschen flüssiger lasst es
gerne so das ist einfach persönliche
präferenz ganz zum schluss kommt noch
mal dass ihn rein und dann ist alles
fertig
[Musik]
das ist jetzt das fertige gericht und
ich finde dieser teller schreit nach
ramadan den habe ich mal ausgeliehen von
meiner schwiegermama letztes jahr habs
grad in meinem schrecken wieder gefunden
also schwierig aber wenn das gerade sie
sorry ich bringe dir vorbei am besten
gefüllt mit irgendwas leckeren das ist
diesmal als typisch wenn man einen
teller sich aus leiten muss man die oder
sollte man den befüllt wieder zurück
bringen einfach aus nettigkeit und das
gericht ist sehr sehr lecker ich hab das
ja wie gesagt schon probiert am ersten
tag und das hat mich einfach umgehauen
aber ganz typisch marokkanisch wir jetzt
übrigens noch wenn ihr kartoffeln
frittiert und obendrüber legt das habe
ich jetzt gelassen ich bin jetzt nicht
so der fan davon dass jetzt noch mal zu
frittieren und also es ist lecker
definitiv aber ich hab' ich habe einfach
gesagt das ist jetzt hier so ein
bisschen meine variante ein bisschen
petersilie für die optik darüber
gestreut und hat abend gibt es noch reis
und salat dazu mein rezept verlinke ich
euch sehr gerne da mache jetzt einfach
den typischen reißen müssen uns das
später schmecken ich wünsche euch jetzt
ganz viel freude beim nachmachen und
verabschiede mich an der stelle und wir
sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal teure
kiki
[Musik]